in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Gail are with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome good to have you where
do you guys live Bakersfield California
Wow it's a bit of a hike to Nashville a
long way to do a debt-free scream we are
driving it - oh well I hope you enjoyed
seeing our beautiful nation driving all
the way across you have it is amazing so
how much debt have you two paid off
we've paid off $82,000 in three years
way to go and huh what what were you
making during that time actually Dave
we're both retired I retired in 2009 and
our combined retirement is now around
120,000 Wow excellent what did you guys
do for a living I was a business manager
first School District mm-hmm and I was a
high school teacher and school
administrator okay so these this income
is what pensions yes yes okay excellent
very very cool
what kind of debt was the 80,000 well we
had a second on our house we had a new
car and we had seven credit cards credit
cards is about $19,000 in credit card
debt and so we you know we were
traveling after we retire we were
traveling in 2011 and I'm kind of a
radio junky and I go across and I hear
this guy talking about finances and
getting out of debt and I'm thinking
that's something we need to do or retire
we felt comfortable but we were in debt
and you know if tragedy came along we
wouldn't even be able to take care of it
so I kept turning the volume up a little
louder and louder waking me up I'm just
so she would kind of get the hint and
then she bought me a gift for Christmas
that that Christmas yeah I bought him
the whole Dave Ramsey kit so that's
something he liked the Financial Peace
University online right okay with the
CDs or the home study kid I guess
well actually we decided to coordinate a
class oh wow and so we bought everything
to coordinate the class oh my goodness
how fun
nothing like teaching something to make
you do it the teacher at heart so that
was right up his alley so he wanted to
do this you bought him the gift did you
go to the class with him I sure did and
I I'm really loving it which by the way
was a bigger gift to him than actually
buying a box of stuff that's right you
going with him is a big deal yes great
that's fine so what was the thing when
you guys were in the class I mean you're
retired yes you're you got $82,000 in
that you decide to teach this class it
isn't like you're you're 18 years old
and naive you know you've been walking
around doing stuff for a while and you
go into this class what was the thing
you learned that you did not expect to
learn one thing I I think for me was the
fact that I wanted to leave a legacy to
my grandsons who are here today and that
meant a lot to me and but probably the
hardest part in the class was opening up
to other people and telling them hey
were this old and we're this must been
dead and that wasn't an easy thing for
me to disclose to everybody and a lot of
these people that were in our first
class were from our church so they knew
us and that was very difficult just to
open up in front of them but after I
kept hearing the stories from them how
much it meant to them then I was free to
just share from then on and Dave I
always thought throughout the years it
seemed like I could control everything I
could get another job teach next to a
class teach at the college get something
in the summer I was the the king of the
the credit card balance transfer I'd
find the deal and move it over and I was
actually sitting in church after we kind
of started going through the material we
had a missionary do a presentation to us
and in church and I'm thinking you know
here we are in debt everybody in here
wants to help but we can't because we're
too much in debt our cells included and
I said at that particular point we're
getting out of debt we're gonna get on
this plan we can get started and we're
going to help teach others to do the
same thing and we've just finished our
fifth FPU class Wow and so we're pretty
excited about that and we've got a lot
of people listening and we've we're just
grateful that we have the opportunity
do that you guys have turned this into a
deal well congratulations we're honored
we appreciate the help teaching the
classes but truthfully they are a blast
to teach because you get to see people
have those aha moments all through the
class oh yeah and it's just really
really rewarding so you now that you're
old hats I mean you've taught this class
five times you're out of debt when
someone hears you paid off $82,000 and
they say how did you do that what do you
tell them the keys to getting control of
your money becoming debt-free are well I
think for us it was sitting them
actually doing a budget before it was
one would buy or someone else would do
something we wouldn't talk about it now
we sit down and we give every dollar a
name we talk about every month we have
our budget meetings now there go pretty
well and and fast and we kind of have
got that all figured out yeah it's just
kind of neat to know how that happens so
for us it was finally you'd think after
47 years of marriage that we would just
be able to to do that easily it wasn't
easy and we started talking about it and
then opening up and talking to others
about it telling them they can do it our
first budget meeting was in the parking
lot at Taco Bell's and I knew I was
probably in for it because it took us
two hours and finally I looked at him
because I'm the free spirit and he's a
nerd and I said I think we're at the end
of that now with it every dollar it's
easy I mean it's been five minutes now
but you know when we first started it
was hard you know it's not the math
that's hard it's it's protecting my
territory getting my little thing I want
on the budget that's right that that's
what's hard and when you give that up
it changes your spiritually and the walk
doesn't it oh it does it really does
so that's pretty incredible well it's
always I mean one of the things that you
say in your in your teachings is it are
you too old to ever start saving you're
ever too old to start and we wanted to
be an example like it's never too late
to start we have regrets we didn't start
when we were 20 because we would have
really been in great shape but we want
our kids and our grandkids to know
if you get started and do it right you
can stay debt-free and it just is really
a freeing just frees your spirit it
really makes us grow and now our son
doesn't son in the daughter Ellen live
in Philadelphia we can drive there and
we can do the visits because we can
afford it and we pay cash there you go
absolutely well you've not only changed
your life and given a lot of people hope
while you're teaching the class but your
kids your grandkids are watching you yes
and they'll talk about this for 20 years
you know they'll talk about this for 30
years I don't remember that time I
watched my my grandmother and my
grandfather do that I watched him do
that and and and so how old are you now
I'm 66 and I will be 68 at the end of
this month so you were 65 and 63 when
you started yes Wow excellent well
nobody said you can't teach an old dog
new tricks as I said it they were wrong
you guys are incredible well thank you
for your example your spirit your heart
I'm very proud of you
thank you I'm very what you do for
people I mean it is incredible - you're
very very neat people this is incredible
all right David and Gail Bakersfield
California they got out of debt while
they were retired yes and they did it
with cash flow $82,000 paid off in 36
months making 120 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
yeah yeah you're not you're not done
until you're done I way to go you two
that is awesome